[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
influence des cabinets de conseil sur la
politique publique le sénat créer une
commission d' enquête
en pleine crise de lakovic 19 le
ministère de la santé a fait appel à
plusieurs cabinets de conseil privé pour
l'accompagner dans sa stratégie
vaccinale mais le recours à ces
organismes se fait-il toujours à bon
escient
dans une telle configuration qui est
décisionnaire
les pouvoirs publics ou bien ces
cabinets privés
à la demande du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes le
sénat a créé en novembre 2021 une
commission denquête pour apporter des
éléments de réponse
en décembre la commission présidée par
arnaud bazin et dont eliane assassi et
la rapporteur a entamé une série de
tables rondes et d'audition pour
recueillir les points de vue de
l'administration d'un côté et des
cabinets de l'autre
les sénateurs veulent tout d'abord
examiner le cheminement de
l'intervention des cabinets privés de la
définition des besoins de
l'administration jusqu'à l'évaluation
finale de leur travail
il s'agit une fine et de mesurer
l'influencé croissante sur les décisions
publiques de ses prestataires privés
les sénateurs souhaitent également
établir une cartographie de
l'intervention de ces cabinets de
conseil
il s'agit de connaître le montant global
des prestations de conseils et leur
évolution et d'identifier les ministères
les plus concernés
la question des conflits d'intérêts des
cabinets influençant la décision
publique et conseillant par ailleurs
d'autres clients dont des entreprises
sera également au coeur des
investigations
le recours à des cabinets privés soulève
une question de déontologie
comment un cabinet peut-il conseiller
l'état et avoir précédemment conseiller
une grande entreprise sur le domaine
d'étude en question
les sénateurs examineront enfin les
questions liées à la souveraineté
bon nombre de ces prestataires
extérieurs sont en effet des sociétés
étrangères
en participant à la définition des
politiques publiques elles ont accès à
des données sensibles en particulier
numérique
que font-elles de ces données collectées
et valorisées
pour en savoir plus consultez les
travaux de la commission d' enquête
[Musique]